a political journalist who promised to
streak down Whitehall if you keep one
more than six percent of the votes in
the general election well he has lived
up to his promise well almost as you can
see now from pictures here they come
do contain some flash photography see
what we did that flash photography Dan
Hodges who writes for The Telegraph
chose to run through central London in
his underwear on and particularly wet
morning he run from Trafalgar Square to
Whitehall in just over three and a half
minutes raising more than a thousand
parts for the Terrence Higgins Trust in
the process dad watch is joining us now
from our studios in central London
thankfully fully dressed as you can see
hello thanks thanks very much how was
that then it was cold Kay it was cold
and it was wet but it was in a in a good
cause and he said to the Terrence
Higgins Trust and also another charity
Elizabeth's legacy of hope so so it was
all in a good cause in the end we could
certainly see it was cold but weren't
you supposed to streak and I looked up
streaking the act of removing one's
clothes and running about in the buff
I thought what happened is it no I
you're right there I looked it up as
well as and it also said that it would
probably have me arrested
I've tried to do that plus I think those
pictures are harrowing enough for your
viewers as it is I think had I taken the
final step it would probably be more
than any of us could tolerate and
obviously there were innocent people
just going about their daily business up
and down Whitehall this morning I think
it would have been unfair to have
inflicted that on them as well why did
it take so long what do you mean take it
along in three and a half minutes that
was a that was a cracking time people
are betting people thought it take me up
to up to six minutes chippie about it a
tool like delighted are you mentally
proud at my time I may I might see if I
can improve on it next year why did it
take since last May to do it is what I
meant
a cowardice absolute abject cowardice
but actually having done it it's
actually quite a liberating experience I
could highly recommend it it's like when
you have those if we've all had those
sort of anxiety nightmares about about
going into work naked or being on the
bus naked I've actually lived through
the experience so life holds no fears
for me now so I I would recommend it I'm
not sure all of us have had those
nightmares done but okay one of your
colleagues been saying to you one of
mean did they tease you until you
eventually had to do it basically I they
did well in fairness there was a UK of
MEP Patrick O'Flynn who consistently and
persistently harassed me on Twitter
asking when I was going to do my naked
streak and I eventually caved in and
also when I discussed it with my wife
and explained that it would be in the
aid of charity she said well of course
you've got to do it so I had my wife
covered
I had Patrick O'Flynn harrassing me
basically Kay I was I was boxed into a
corner who the people that were greeting
you at the end was that your missus yes
it was my what my wife and my son who
were who were cheering me on at the end
was he embarrassed no he seemed to be
till he was delighted it got him it got
him out of school for the morning so he
was he was pleased okay now what tell us
why this happened what was the reason
behind it well I
back in 2012 a lifetime ago sent out a
very innocent tweet in which I said if
you keep broke 6% more than 6% of the
general election I would streak down
Whitehall and obviously they got 12% so
in truth I suppose especially to run
down and run all the way back up again
so so erroneous was my prediction but
it's it's not the first erroneous
prediction by me and I'm sure it won't
be the last but at least this one was
able to raise money for a couple of very
worthy causes people in the gallery
saying you don't look in too bad a shape
did you not eat too much a Christmas or
something that was in training that was
it i starved myself over over Christmas
that's what the eight months before I
was I was just working my way up to it
okay any other predictions before we let
you go no that's it for now that's it
for now but you'll be the
No are you sure you should we don't want
to make a prediction for the EU
referendum when it might be yeah we're
gonna stay in and if we don't stay in
i'll run naked down Whitehall again as
that okay just just gonna write that
down so if we don't stay in the EU then
you will run down Whitehall hall again
make it you said naked didn't it well
might on my definition of naked okay
it's it's great you raise a thousand
pounds for the Terrence Higgins Trust as
well than you I did yes great good good
sport thanks for joining us on Sky News
appreciate it thanks a lot